espero que para estas alturas de tu vida
ya estás familiarizado con el concepto
de ángulo y sobre todo con cómo se miden
los ángulos en grados por ejemplo yo
puedo dibujar un ángulo de 30 grados y
se va a ver más o menos así esté por
aquí sería un ángulo de 30 grados
dibujábamos una línea aquí y decíamos
que tenía 30 grados es decir la abertura
entre estas dos líneas es de 30 grados
si nosotros quisiéramos dibujar un
ángulo de 90 grados hasta lo poníamos
con este simbólico que tenemos aquí un
ángulo de 180 grados pues de hecho sería
como tener una línea recta sería darle
media vuelta al círculo medio giro
completo y si nosotros tuviéramos por
ejemplo un ángulo de 360 grados pues
damos un giro completo o una vuelta
completa a una circunferencia de hecho
en el patinaje artístico muchas veces
dicen oh este patinador de una vuelta de
360 quiere decir 360 grados o esto
termino escuchado en las patinetas dio
un 360 es decir su patineta giro 360
grados dio una vuelta entera pero te has
preguntado por qué 360 grados por qué
decir que una
entera son 360 grados y bueno hay
algunas teorías sobre el por qué el giro
de 360 grados es una vuelta entera y
estas son debido a nuestra cultura
una hipótesis son los calendarios incas
los cuales tenían años de tan solo 360
días y no son los únicos calendarios de
360 días y es que los astrónomos incas
habían llegado a la conclusión de que
las cosas parecían moverse a 1 entre 360
por día me refiero a las cosas celestes
es decir las cosas en el cielo según
ellos se movían a esa cantidad la otra
teoría son los sistemas de numeración
babilónicos y sumerios y es que ellos
tenían 60 símbolos de numeración
mientras nosotros solamente tenemos 10
esto quiere decir que si nosotros
dividimos las cosas entre 10 ellos
probablemente las tengan que dividir
entre 60 ellos tomaban un círculo y este
círculo dividido en 6 triángulos
equiláteros y cada uno de esos
triángulos equiláteros lo dividían en 60
pedacitos iguales por lo tanto un
círculo tenía 360 grados es decir un
sistema de numeración sexagesimal pero
lo que yo quiero ver en este vídeo es
otra forma alternativa de llamar a los
ángulos y es que esta nueva forma de
llamar a los ángulos es mucho más
elegante y más pura más matemáticamente
pura pues vamos a ponerle nombre a los
ángulos no de una forma que tenga que
ver con la astronomía o las culturas
antiguas o las influencias de una
cultura sobre nosotros esta vez lo que
quiero ver es cómo se miden los ángulos
en radiales y en verdad esta forma de
ver las cosas es mucho más elegante y
mucho más puro y se utiliza más en
matemáticas formales por lo tanto voy a
dibujar aquí una circunferencia no me
quedó tan mal la circunferencia pero
bueno este de aquí va a ser su centro ya
tengo su centro y por lo tanto voy a
dibujar su radio éste de que iba a ser
su radio
hasta aquí va todo normal esto lo hemos
visto varias veces y fíjense la palabra
radial seguramente va a tener que ver
con radio no creen y bueno ya que tengo
ya que el radio voy a dibujar un ángulo
theta entonces voy a agarrar este ángulo
y este ángulo le voy a llamar el ángulo
theta pero va a cumplir
y muy importante este ángulo es el
ángulo que se forma al sub tender el
radio a lo largo de la circunferencia
como como como si imagínense que yo
tengo el radio y lo voy a poner sobre
esta circunstancia y por lo tanto el
ángulo que se forma al sub tender este
arco o dicho de otra manera el ángulo
que voy a obtener desde el punto inicial
hasta el punto final de este arco le voy
a llamar theta por lo tanto vamos a
escribirlo entonces este de aquí este
arco me va a suspender este ángulo está
tan psuv tender el arco va a suspender
este ángulo theta pero bueno aquí hay
una cosa muy importante nosotros
habíamos dicho que este arco valía r
es decir me estoy fijando en este ángulo
que me dé este arco de medida r y bueno
si encuentro este ángulo de medida r a
eso lo voy a definir como como que creen
pues claro como un radiante entonces voy
a decir que teta es igual a un radial
si él
ar con que se dibuja sobre la
circunferencia al abrir este ángulo de
tam tiene como medida un radio por lo
tanto así es como define este ángulo
theta por lo tanto le voy a poner el
nombre de un radiante está va a ser
igual a un radiante y perfecto ya cuando
tengo una nueva definición de una medida
angular y es que esta definición me va a
servir bastante porque esta definición
me va a poder ayudar entonces una
equivalencia con las unidades de grados
que nosotros conocemos por ejemplo vamos
a intentar hacer un par de experimentos
para ver qué es lo que sale si yo lo que
quisiera fijarme es en una vuelta entera
como esto lo hemos visto varias veces
cómo podría yo definir entonces o cómo
podría yo saber el valor de un radial
justo esto es lo que voy a buscar a
partir de ahora entonces imagínense que
yo tengo aquí lo voy a tratar de dibujar
voy a tener mi circunferencia entonces
este va a ser mi diámetro y ahí viene
otra vez el problema de dibujar
circunferencias este de aquí va a ser mi
diámetro y no me quedó nada bien
voy a agarrar otro color mejor y este de
aquí va a ser mi circunferencia
perfecto y yo lo que quiero fijarme
ahora es qué es lo que pasaba si yo le
daba una vuelta entera a esta
circunstancia es decir tenía un ángulo
de 360 grados como puedo ver este ángulo
de 360 grados de una manera equivalente
con nuestra nueva medida angular es
decir en radiales el perímetro de esta
circunferencia en términos del radio y
esto ya lo sabemos si se acuerdan un
poco esto lo viste hace mucho tiempo la
longitud de la circunferencia o el
perímetro de esta circunferencia en
términos del radio nos dábamos por una
fórmula que nosotros conocíamos como pi
por el diámetro o dicho de otra manera
si lo queremos pensar en términos del
radio y no del diámetro solamente de
esta distancia entonces toda esta
distancia todo el perímetro de música
conferencia estaba dada por 2
efe
y por el diámetro por lo tanto podemos
decir que en medida angular en radiales
todas pero toda esta vuelta completa a
la circunferencia vale 2 por el radio
pero nosotros también sabemos que esto
en medida de ángulos vale 360 grados por
lo tanto ya que tengo mi primera gran
equivalencia o mi primera gran igualdad
pero bueno aquí hay que tener un poco de
cuidado porque dije algo que puede
resultar erróneo porque el perímetro del
círculo es 2000 por el radio mientras
que en medida angular nuestro ángulo va
a valer 2 pi radian es 12 para radio
esto es por la definición que tenemos de
un radiante recuerda que un radiante lo
habíamos definido como el ángulo que se
va a formar al tener un arco de la
medida de un radio por lo tanto ya
sabemos que darle una vuelta entera a la
circunferencia en esta medida de
radiales
2b radiales mientras que en la medida de
ángulos tiene 360 grados es justo lo que
habíamos dicho y por lo tanto aquí está
como les decía mi primera
2 y radiant es es igual a 360 grados lo
que es lo mismo a dar una vuelta entera
y en lugar de poner grados aquí le voy a
poner grados escrito para que vean que
al final es una medida angular y estamos
hablando de puras medidas angulares y no
nos confundamos pues esta igualdad habla
de dos ángulos que son iguales una
medida en radiales y el otro en grados y
bueno qué va a pasar si yo divido todo
esto entre dos me queda que pie radiales
es lo mismo que 360 entre dos es decir
180 grados no que grados no voy a
ponerlo aquí grados muy bien y ya que
tengo las dos igualdades más importantes
para hacer un cambio de grados a
radiales y de radiales sagrados 2p
radiales es igual a 360 grados o dicho
de otra manera y radiales es igual a 180
grados la mitad de un giro entero son
igual a pie radiales y recuerda bastante
bien estas dos igualdades porque la
mayoría de las soluciones de problemas
de transformar de radiant en sagrados y
de grados radiales tienen que ver con
estas dos igualdades
pero ahora mi pregunta es si yo quisiera
saber el valor de un solo radial de
solamente un radial cuánto vale en
grados a pues entonces tendría un
radiales igual y voy a pasar del otro
lado a pitt hecho dejame escribirlo
porque esto parece un poco de magia y un
poco de vudú y así va a parecer más
formal
yo voy a dividir ambos lados entre pin y
así vas a ver de dónde salen y entre
pineda uno por lo tanto tengo un
radiante va a ser igual a 180 entre pi
grados 180 entre pin grados y ya tenemos
el valor de un radiante ya sabemos
cuánto vale en radiante en grados y si
yo quisiera el revés y si yo quisiera
saber cuánto es un grado en radiales es
decir el valor de solamente un grado de
un grado como lo conocemos en el valor
de radiales en el valor de radiales como
le podemos hacer bueno pues vamos a
partir de la igualdad la igualdad de
spears irradian es es igual a 180 grados
esto es lo que sabemos y recuerden que
ésta va a ser una de nuestras
equivalencias favoritas para hablar de
radiales y grados ahora lo que voy a
hacer es dividir ambos lados entre 180
80 entre 181 y por lo tanto me queda que
entre 180 radiales es lo mismo que un
grado solamente un grado y entre 180
radiales es igual a un grado y por lo
tanto ya sé cuánto vale un radial en
términos de grados y un grado en
términos de radiales y tal vez esto te
suene un poco confuso para mí fue un
poco confuso cuando lo vi por primera
vez sin embargo después de que veamos
algunos ejemplos en los siguientes
vídeos te va a ser acostumbrando más al
lenguaje tanto de radiales como de
grados y te va a ser mucho más fácil la
conversión de grados a radiales y de
radiales sagrados pero eso sí lo que es
muy importante es que recuerdes estas
dos igualdades dos pirra tienes es igual
a 360 grados o en su dado caso irradian
es es igual a 180 grados con estas
equivalencias saldrán todos los
problemas que vamos a ver así que para
que quede todo mucho más claro no te
pierdas nuestros siguientes vídeos